music doesn't just affect you physically
but mentally emotionally spiritually
and physically and that's why it's so
powerful i didn't think
you know 30 years later now that i would
be proud to say i'm putting people to
sleep
you know all around the world with my
music you have to keep checking in with
yourself
and re-listening and re-asking yourself
how you feel it's all about awareness
and there is evan how are you good
barry and i connected inside genius
network
uh which is an awesome group for
entrepreneurs trying to get to the next
level
and he did this great 10-minute talk
about the impact of music and i love
music i have multiple playlists for
different vibes
i was asked yesterday in your morning
routine what is the most important thing
that that has to be there i said music
every time it's got to be music so
walk us through barry i mean i've heard
the overview but for my audience and i
want to i got some specific questions i
want to ask you
the the power of music and why people
need to have it in their
as a part of not just their morning
routine but regular daily routine
yeah i think most of us think we know
like everything about music but
it's really about looking at it from
another way and beyond art and
entertainment
how you can use music to navigate your
emotions for whatever
it is you want your purpose to be so you
know
like like i love your book is all about
perfect
um you know your purpose and believing
in what you want to do and putting that
out into the world
but how do we manage our energy to be
able to do that effectively
so if you think of music more as a tool
to
navigate your emotions more effectively
as opposed to just art and entertainment
and not just creating
playlists you know that we love but what
would happen if we created them for
different emotions
so that when our energy is down right
and we want to lift it up we know
exactly what piece we're going to play
we have a playlist that's ready for that
or the other way around you know in the
evening when you want to wind down at
night
because your mind's so busy and you
can't get to sleep having a playlist to
be able to do that and
it's really about bridging where am i
now where do i want to go
and what piece of music is going to take
me there i love it so i love to say
music is the fastest way to change your
state
you know remember how you feel in music
is the fastest way to get out into a
different state i think too often we put
on music for how we're currently feeling
so if you feel really sad you put on sad
music and then what does that do it just
keeps you
feeling sad as opposed to saying hey
listen maybe maybe you should feel sad
like maybe something happened that is
worth feeling sad over
but if you want to be happy don't put on
sad music it's just going to keep you
where you are
so okay so you you in the presentation
we're talking about you had
you know morning playlist you had an
after uh lunchtime
or afternoon playlist that was more uh
tropical vibe
or touring the world kind of vibe and
then the evening playlist
it does it start with how do i want if
i'm putting this into a morning routine
is it how do i want to feel today
and then what songs make me feel that
way it's like is that how you help
people build
playlists yeah or even looking at your
schedule for the day i'm sure you know
what you're going to do during your day
so you know if you have a big leadership
meeting or a high energy interview you
don't want to start your day
listening to relaxation music you know
so
i think it's knowing yourself
inventorying your music and
knowing what pieces take you where is a
great start but we also you know the
science behind it evan as well that um
when we start our day in a place of
gratitude
that we can just build on that so the
institute of heart math
actually shows that when we're in these
states of gratitude appreciation
compassion
that it's not just affecting our
emotions but it's affecting our physical
body as well
so our hearts when we're in that place
of gratitude start beating at smooth
orderly rhythms
and also it slows our brain waves down
to
alpha brainwave states as well when
we're in that and that's the perfect
state to
create in so if you start your day in a
place of gratitude
it doesn't have to just be relaxation
music though either within that
gratitude playlist like my playlist is
awesome
it has like slime a family stone thank
you for letting me be myself
right dido thank you louis armstrong
what a wonderful world
so you kind of see where i'm going with
this you know and that puts me in a
place
of appreciation to start my day and then
i just kind of amp it up from there or
wind it down from there
based on what i need during my day
do you intentionally pair that with
something some kind of activity
or is it just it's on as you're going
throughout your day so
example like are you doing it while
you're meditating or why are you going
for a walk or while you're brushing your
teeth
or is it just hey i'm i'm doing my usual
i'm checking the phone whatever but i've
got this on the background which helps
me remember
yeah i mean sometimes it's a little of
both it's based on what i need in that
day
you know so i can start off listening to
sly in the family stone thank you for
letting me be myself but then
if i want to set my intention for my day
and move more into
my heart with that you know then i
listen to a piece of music
that's going to bring me into more into
that expansive space of gratitude where
i'm feeling more emotion i would and
listen more intently at that phase of it
so
it's um you know it reminds me of i
think what
was said if you t if you give a man a
fish he eats for a day
if you teach a man to fish he eats for a
lifetime so it's really
not me saying okay here's what to plug
in it's you
knowing what takes you to each state and
identifying that
so that when you reach that state you
know how to get there
and sometimes you're right it is moving
and sometimes it is
acknowledging the emotion first you know
if you're sad sometimes you want to move
through that emotion
but also how long do you want to stay
there you know you don't want to move
it into a pity party but you do want to
process the emotion
and i think most of us you know are in
this day and age or a lot of us
are geared towards looking for a panacea
or a way to numb
things as well so it's important to
recognize the emotion and then move
through it and
elevate it so identify it release it and
then
do what i do i call it a tuning so once
you identify and release then you can
attune
i like it so i i've just intuitively
felt like
music was fantastic and it really helped
me but i never had any of the science or
data or anything behind it so
i was super excited when you came on and
did your presentation and to have you on
here too
um talk to me about
sometimes i'll have my playlist that i
just go through
and i have a believe playlist which
which i have on during the day or my
productivity music playlist
but there are also sometimes like right
now for the past
eight days probably i've just had one
song on repeat
uh-huh yeah uh selena gomez my dilemma
uh and i don't know it's the beat
there's just something to it
and just on repeat like while i'm
working well i muted it for this so this
isn't crazy on the background but
i found that i'll get into zones where
there's just one song that i have and
for a day or four days and i probably
drive the people around me
nina and my wife patients like are we
still listening to this song
talk to us about that where it becomes
this ear worm that we just have to keep
on is that is it good to stay in that
zone how does it serve us or not serve
us
what are your thoughts yeah well how
does it make you feel when you listen to
it would be my first question
um i find that when i when i first put
it on i was like i can't wait the song
is still in my head for some reason you
know i guess probably because i listened
to it all day yesterday
it's still in my head it still makes me
feel great uh it's got a nice beat to it
i'm on my trampoline jumping while i'm
working
but then at some point it kind of just
fades into the background but i'm still
jumping i think it goes subconscious you
know that i'm not
actively paying attention to the music
anymore but i still have the beat and
the energy from the song that i'm now
pouring into
the work and you know five hours goes by
and the song's still on repeat
i don't even notice that the song is
still on it's just kind of there
but i still have the the energy
and jumping up and down to the b yeah so
there's a couple of things
in there that's why i ask you first of
all i think it's great to have one song
i call that your happy song so no matter
what you're doing
you know it kind of puts you in a state
that you want to whether it's happy or
whether it's for creativity
you can have one song that you sink your
teeth into and we change
you know on a daily basis our energy our
emotions change so as long as you feel
it's still serving you
and it's getting you to where you want
to go i say utilize it
but also what's going on it's creating
what
is has been researched as
autobiographical memories
so music has the power as you know you
can listen to a song from 30 years ago
and say wow that used to be my jam
i love that song and it's still even
listening to it to this day
makes me feel a certain way so what
you're doing with that is
you're creating a new autobiographical
memory with that song
because now you're connecting that to
putting you in a creative state in a
flow state
and not only that the aspect of you
moving into rhythm with it
is what's called entrainment so
entrainment is when
an internal rhythm can synchronize to an
external rhythm
so your heart rate can actually
synchronize
to a piece of music and we can target
different states by doing that
for example relaxation could be at 60
beats per minute
that selena gomez song probably in the
you know between 70 and 80 beats that
kind of real
central vibe and it kind of has a beat
to it and you know can keep you right
there
so we're really what i call and you
probably remember this from my talk
you're becoming the dj of your life
right just like dj's program beats they
know how many beats per minute a song is
they're navigating their audience's
energy
you're navigating your own energy to put
you in a place of service and that's
awesome
one of the things i love doing that
people find crazy is i
play pretty much every song at 1.25
speed
wow okay so you speed it up a little bit
so by deep because youtube has a setting
where you can go i basically do
everything on youtube
if i use the youtube app the music app
you can't adjust the speeds like why is
everything so slow
but pretty much every single song i play
at 1.25 speed
and then i'll play it for people and
then i'll play them the original ones
like wow it sounds so slow
i think it's just more happy i don't
know it makes
it gives me more energy maybe it's the
whole heartbeat rhythm
you know i want to be beaten at a faster
rate does anything come to mind where i
say that like every single song pretty
much
unless it's like it's just a crazy crazy
fast song but for the most part every
song
yeah i mean i think i think you have an
awareness of what works for you and
that's the first thing i always tell
people
to do is it's not just go by
recommendations
do what feels good for you and if you
have an awareness that you want to
move it a little bit faster you probably
want to get a lot done
you know you you seem like you want to
you know there's a lot you want to do in
your lifetime
and that if you just go a little bit
faster you can probably get more done
and you know move through different
states um
and target those states that's what came
to me in terms of doing it but what i
want to say is you know this is
all an experiment as well you know for
me
i started off as a pop producer you know
in new york city i grew up in the bronx
i was like producing urban music and i
was doing
a lot of club and house music at the
beginning of that
and i was became very stressed out as
being a music producer in new york city
and started losing my love
for music so i said wow how can i come
back to the
my heart and my love of this and stop
working on a four-minute song for a
hundred hours a day
and instead what would happen if i just
let the music kind of come through me
and i set my metronome to 60 beats per
minute
so i was my own experiment to move
through anxiety and stress i didn't
think
you know 30 years later now that i would
be proud to say i'm putting people to
sleep
you know all around the world with my
music so it is an
experiment constantly because you're
constantly changing
but knowing that music doesn't just
affect you physically but mentally
emotionally spiritually and physically
and that's why it's so powerful
and when you can start to plug that into
your day to navigate your mission and
your vision
that's the difference
so i love what you're saying why when
one of the reasons why i love it is
because
i've been doing it intuitively but never
had a map to follow it's just been
exploration but no map no guidance no
like best practices or anything to
follow
the first thing that comes to my head is
if i take
the selena gomez song for example if i
take the earworm songs that have been
you know the ones that i've had on
repeat for days for sometimes
and then whatever the bpm is times 1.25
like maybe that's an ideal maybe
instead of just playing every song at
1.25 i should be optimizing for
80 beats per minute right so that would
be the first thing i agree you could
recognize
and identify what the beats per minute
for that is and there's some great apps
that do that like i have an
app in my phone called bpm yeah so
whenever i
have a song that i listen to and i like
i'm you know
going like this in the bpm to see what
that is and identify that's like i
thought so because i'm
i'm pretty good at it you know and
saying oh that's about 60 beats per
minute that's
73 beats per minute but um i think it's
great to have an app where you can do it
and
and start targeting your states because
when you're you're moving into those
states evan
as well your body is amazing right
you're starting to produce hormones that
are beneficial to you doing whatever you
need to do
so when you're feeling like you're
rewarding yourself by listening to a
piece of music
your body starts to produce dopamine
which is a pleasure hormone and it's
it's
it starts to diminish your stress
hormones cortisol
so so many people who are reaching for
pharmaceuticals and nutraceuticals
you know and i understand that i'm not
i'm not putting anyone down people need
to do what they need to do
and there's no right or wrong but why
not have a third category which i call
acousticals
right where you're tapping into music
try it first low cost
non-invasive no side effects and
see if that works for you and you can
work with navigating your energy with
you know in combination or you know
finding harmony in another way
i love it dude so i'm speaking at an
event my first like in-person event
coming up uh you know through cohort and
they asked me hey what do you want your
walk-on song to be
and i say sia unstoppable because that's
that was been that's been my walk on
song
but sia unstoppable right where the beat
drops but at 1.25 speed
yeah or you need me to write like a
theme song for you man like tailored for
you when you walk out on that stage
we could do that too yeah but yeah
my question there around that is
when i first heard you talk my
my initial thoughts went okay i need to
have different playlists for different
moods more in the evening afternoon or
even just on breaks or even just hey if
i want to be more mindful now or more
creative now or more whatever now then i
need to
having music to help me get me there
we'll get because that can happen
there are some songs you put on and like
i have to sit up and just start moving
like it doesn't have to take
20 minutes of meditation with with your
acousto
therapy acoustic yeah you're right
that's the point
yeah exactly it happens it happens it
happens fast yeah
so my first insight from your first talk
was
find different songs for different bpms
that can match the mood i want to go
after
what i'm wondering now is
the impact of just instead of finding a
song what if we find songs that
that we know and like but then just
alter the speed
yeah that's cool also why not yeah i
mean you have the technology to do it
you know but what happens if you want to
slow it down
you know you can you can do that as well
there's apps to do all of that
is there is there an easy way i'm going
to move my laptop now i'm taking notes
here
is there is there an easy way to to
put a song to a certain bpm i i think
there is an app for that but you
probably would want to type in
you know shifting uh speed shift i know
there there is in my software but i
don't know if there's an
easy app to do that you know it's like
in pro tools i can do that
fairly easily and just change beats per
minute of it but
i i always think with all the apps that
we have out there that there be a way to
do that
if not maybe it's time to create one so
this is the next
berry and creativity barry and evan
create it yeah let's do it
give us give me your favorite songs and
then
it couldn't be the same song i wonder if
i wonder if selena gomez could put me to
sleep
i wonder like i wonder if if we slowed
it down to 65
does it have the same impact
yeah well here's the other thing with
sleep music though and i will say this
again not that there's any right and
wrong but
lyrics tend to put us more back into our
thinking mind
you know when we're listening to songs
with with words
and then before sleep we tend to get
caught up in the lyric and like oh i
love this lyric or i don't
and that keeps our you know our
analytical brain
you know in term in terms of wanting to
move into a more trance state it's
putting you back into the analytical
mind
so music for sleep you might want to use
that to bridge
into more of a sleep state and that
again is it when it comes to beats per
minute like if you're
in your high thinking mind all day you
know probably you're in beta
brainwave state which is your analytical
mind that's
doing all this you probably want to
bridge yourself down
and maybe you start off with you know an
up-tempo
club jam or you know that's more that's
faster
and then you keep bridging down so meet
yourself where you're at
again asking yourself where am i now
where do i want to go what's going to
take me there
and create a playlist that's going to
bridge you down to sleep as opposed to
just drastically taking you from one
state to the other
so that's interesting so auditory is the
worst way for me to learn
i'll zone out on audiobooks hearing
really
sucks for me uh compared to visual like
the fact that i can see you
versus it just being a audio only
podcast is so much easier
i zone out of almost all lyrics like i
don't even know what they're saying
um my son just remembers him like how do
you remember the song
even as i'm singing songs because i've
heard it so many times i don't even know
what i'm saying
if you ask me if there's something that
just it doesn't connect for whatever
reason
the lyrics go through but what i love
about this is uh
you're giving different tools that
people can use so the first one was bpm
you know upper beat will make you feel
more energetic a slower bpm will help
you feel a little more relaxed the
second is the actual lyrics of the song
if they're more aggressive you'll be
more aggressive more grateful even more
great like thank you
daido is not just how slow it is it's
the lyrics and the message
are there other things this is why i
love it like the science are there other
things
so bpm lyrics what else am i paying
attention to to
try to create the ideal mindset shift
yeah so here for me is the biggest one
and okay and there's not necessarily
science behind it so it's great to have
the science to plug in
but i also feel that science is catching
up to spirituality
and things that we've known for
thousands of years you know like the
chanting of ohm
is now being studied and it's showed to
in the brain with fmri
studies that it actually activates the
part of the brain that's connected to
peacefulness
for example we've known this right for
thousands of years but now
it's validated and i can present it in
medical conferences
to doctors and they understand it more
because it's validated
but the things that aren't validated
doesn't mean it's not powerful
so when i'm listening to a piece of
music and even if someone recommends it
to me and say
just this song has great science behind
it it's perfect beats per minute
it's been shown to do this or that i
listen to it
and i ask myself two questions one does
this make me feel
expansive right like i'm standing on top
of a mountain my
my arms are wide open which i'm going
like this right
and i have a feeling of freedom it makes
me feel free
and unencumbered or does it make me feel
contracted
you know like i want to close up i don't
feel safe it sounds like you know nails
on
a board for me so regardless of someone
recommending it to you just like
medicine the most powerful medicine we
can create is individualized medicine
you know broccoli might be great for me
but you might be allergic to it
how does it make you feel when you put
it in your system
and it's the same with music most of us
think that music is something
that happens to us but it's also
something that's happening
in us and so if we can connect with them
and say how does this make me feel
internally when i hear it and you say
wow i love this song every time i listen
to that selena song
you know it puts me in a state where i
just feel like i'm in flow i don't have
to think
i can get out of my mind chatter and i'm
like in creation
like that that's an expansive state for
you and you want to be able to go back
to that so that's the key
contracted or expansive when you're
listening to it
and then you start to you kind of start
to see patterns of what you like and
what you don't
at this point in your life you know it
might change in a month
and that's the thing you have to keep
checking in with yourself and
re-listening
and re-asking yourself how you feel it's
all about awareness
so so give us a tool kit right so the
only tools
i'm doing that and i love it uh how does
this hung me feel
i like it great i'm gonna have it on
repeat for as long as i like it
uh that also then leads me to hey maybe
i'll like
other songs what else is selena gomez
sung right so that kind of
goes down that path or youtube has
recommended for this song
listen to these songs but i'm wondering
if there's
a more beyond just the how it makes me
feel
is there is there a way to get there
to discover better songs for the moves
we want to give us
instead of having to listen to
everything so you know
selena if you said hey it's um 80 beats
per minute that already gives me
something to
classify hey let me find other songs or
80 b's per minute
if her her lyrics are about his
relationship and her dilemma i don't
know what she's talking about so that's
not
impacting me but for other people if
it's more aspiration or positive lyrics
are there other is it instrumental
versus not
is it i mean are there other things that
you could break down a song that lead to
the
how does it make me feel to make finding
other songs a little easier
yeah and also i think one of the great
things about finding
finding songs is that when you start to
create your
your initial playlist right so if you
just look at your inventory now and
didn't worry about it
and instead of saying oh i'm looking for
gratitude
right just go through your playlist and
start playing songs and then write down
how they make you feel for each one
then start to sort them into playlists
so you could navigate them
but another thing to do is create a
movement with it you know like you and i
are talking about it on this talk
now if you have a thousand listeners all
listening to this and we start posting
hey this is what i
listen to for gratitude this is what i
like to listen to
when i work out this is what i like to
listen to when i'm trying to get
inspired or motivated
this is what i listen to when i'm doing
breathing techniques
then you know we can pull from each
other's and try different things because
obviously we're at this great time where
our technologies are giving us the
ability to go check it out
youtube spotify apple use amazon you
should be able to find whatever songs
people are posting
and check them out the other thing i
think is
is just some rules of thumb is create a
program with it
and just like everything else when you
create a program and you give it
consistency it's going to have more
of a transformational effect so start
out
just like you would creating a new
nourishment program or a new diet
just start out with the basics you know
three times a day
start give yourself nourishment in the
morning musical nourishment i call it
it's just like you break your fast of
what you're eating what song
one song just start with do you want to
start your day with today
and then as your day unfold if you set
your intention with that
and now you see some challenges coming
into your day and you start to get out
of that space that you were in
again where am i now where do i want to
go what piece of music is going to take
me there
but i think in midday revitalizing your
energy
and uh with a song that takes you
someplace else in the world i call it a
five minute musical vacation
is just a great practice to do because
it exposes you to the culture of
different music
all around the world it creates great
conversation
it educates you and it takes you out of
your environment that you're currently
in
and if you just close your eyes with it
or for you if you're a visual
you want to you might want to see a
video that takes you to jamaica
and there's guys jamming you know and
playing reggae music with it
and then third listen to that piece of
music at night that's going to wind you
down
i think of it like uh in the evening you
have a a sweet tooth or something
something that's like dessert for you
sonically and start with those three
things and do it for a month
and you'll start to know yourself a lot
more wow this
song doesn't work for me now and keep
adjusting
and watch what happens after a month for
you in terms of
becoming the dj of your life you're
going to be able to navigate your energy
more
take the 30-day sonic berry challenge
that's it let's go absolutely dude i
could talk to you
all day but for people who want to dive
deeper in your world
learn more about what you do where do
you want them to go where are we sending
them
yeah just go to barrygoldsteinmusic.com
you can find me on most platforms
i'm also doing involved in a great
summit that's the
sound healing summit that's going on
from august 9th to 13th that's on my
instagram page and linked in my link
tree so if you want to know more about
music sound and vibration and dive
deeper in
it's something great to go to and listen
to my music i love talking about it
but there's nothing you know we could
talk about music all day but it's all
about
listening and experiencing it and i also
have a book so i'll give you a
a mindless plug here it's called the
secret language of the heart i also have
evan's book here with me
and there it is wow so it's all good i
love talking
i appreciate the time man and listen i
took notes i don't usually pull up my
laptop on a
ig live because i'm don't want to be
disrespectful i was like i've got to
write this down i'm going to forget it
so
i'm sending to myself appreciate
everything you put out
and do it it's healing and i love that
you're stepping up and and
speaking at events and being more
visible and saying yes to being a talker
and
i love it and thank you for joining us
today and can't wait to see you at the
next meeting
my pleasure thanks again evan and thank
you for all that you're doing in the
world really appreciate it
thanks barry if you want to see my
recent one-on-one with matthew
mcconaughey check out my interview right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there sometimes it's not about what
decision you make just make one and
commit to it
self-determination and fate
intentionality and trust i mean
it's always a balance of those two